[Music]
heather locklear arrested and charged
with domestic violence and battery on a
police officer ET can't confirm the 56
year old actress was taken into custody
Sunday night after a domestic
disturbance call close to 10:00 p.m.
at a residence in the Los Angeles area a
source tells ET quote Heather has been
spiraling out of control lately and
Sunday she hit rock bottom according to
the Ventura County Sheriff's Department
things got intense
when they arrived miss Locklear was
uncooperative with the deputies and
actually battered three of our deputies
authorities say Locklear allegedly
battered a boyfriend at the residence
before they arrived our source adds
she's doing her best to get back on
track but her boyfriend is no help at
all in fact the two of them fight a lot
now those closest to the former Melrose
Place star are concerned about her
well-being quote her friends and family
are telling her it is time to go back to
rehab she needs it badly she was
released Monday morning after posting a
20 thousand dollar bail Locklear is
scheduled to appear in court on March
13th
[Music]